hello and welcome to the Daily climate
show coming up today
time to reflect after this year's cop 27
can the landmark loss and damage
agreement deliver and are the Summits
fit for purpose
the beginning of the end for burning
waste in Africa will have the latest on
a new partnership with the aim to end
the dangerous practice by 2014.
solar farms in outer space how your
Kettle toaster or TV could one day be
powered by electricity beamed thousands
of miles down to earth
and a new Gadget designed to scare
sharks in order to save them
[Music]
hello and welcome to the Daily climate
show where we track the changes to our
world and interrogate some of the
potential solutions to The Climate
crisis now it's only been a couple of
days since the cop 27 climate Summit
came to an end and it's clear it's going
to take time some time to establish what
was agreed at the summit but how the
promises will actually be achieved now
Nations decided on a fund to help poorer
countries cope with the extreme weather
events caused by global warming also
known as loss and damage it's something
that's been pushed by developing
countries for more than 30 years and
what's unclear however is how the
process will work and how the money will
actually be given well joining me now is
Dr sachindra Prasad chair of the Pacific
Islands forum and the head of fiji's
Delegation at cop at 27th thanks for
joining us on the daily climate show Dr
Prasad so first of all a lot of
unanswered quests questions about this
loss and damage fund but in reality how
would you like to see it work
a good good afternoon to you and listen
yeah my ideal would be that there's a
single Consolidated loss and damage fund
established under the unfcc and that
global resources flow into it and Via a
central fund countries who are on the
front lines of
climate change are able to access these
funds easily and on scale in order to
respond to the growing damages in
reality here we have about 12 months to
think it through
there might be a combination of funds
under essential fund within the unfcc
process and member states countries will
be working together very hard with a
deep sense of urgency to try to see what
are the modalities and what are the ways
in which a different financing
instruments
especially via the international
financial institutions for example or
through funds would be able to Anchor
and support a central loss and damage
fund so fantastic progress that the
political support globally has been
secured and now we have to work very
hard to get the details in place and I'm
sure there's Global consensus
to ensure that the details fall in place
soon absolutely and Dr Prasad you you
mentioned the word urgency there and
there'll be vulnerable Nations like for
example Pakistan who will need that
money very urgently but do you feel that
the vulnerable Nations uh were served by
cop 27.
so we are from uh Fiji as you know one
other and small island states of the
Pacific who we say are also on the front
of the front lines of climate change we
would have very much wanted the triage
the trio of uh of mitigation adaptation
and loss and damage the three parts of
the climate uh uh framework to have
fallen in place decades ago because uh
loss and damage is something that is not
new has been happening for decades now
so we keep on stressing the point of
urgency we have to this is not in our
hands the global North has to accept the
same sense of urgencies we as we we are
stressing we just have to work very hard
and be persistent and try to secure a
secure a deal granted we are frustrated
but in these things we can't be
frustrated because our people and
communities as in Pakistan they rely on
on this one to deliver in in real time
right now not in some distant future
and it's important isn't it because that
that final agreement at cop27 it didn't
really acknowledge the need to wean
ourselves off of fossil fuels this will
be quite worrying for vulnerable Nations
like Fiji
so look we are absolutely clear the era
of fossil Fields is gone there's no
feasible scenario in which the planet
can stay within 1.5 in which fossil fuel
is also part uh part of the future and
we hope that all countries do their bit
and lot more uh them that is needed to
stay within 1.5 if it lose 1.5 then both
the the loss and damage and the
adaptation cost will just Skyrocket and
forget about Skyrocket so many thousands
of Our Lives will be lost to uh climate
catastrophes each year there will be
millions and tens of millions of people
forced to relocate from their homes so
the other scenario of not securing 1.5
by not weaning off our addiction to
fossil fuel is just uh it's just so
catastrophic okay and so we have a
narrow window time we have a few years
in which to get this right own countries
the global North Global South have to do
a lot more than what is on the table to
get us back into 1.5 and certainly
fossil fuel uh we we accept the need for
uh just transition is from small island
States we also ask it please also accept
our plea for just existence as well and
that just transition should be
accelerated and that our dependency and
fossil fuel should be reduced there
dramatically much faster and within this
within this decade and Dr Prasad very
briefly uh in talking to you today your
tone is very optimistic but what do you
feel the legacy of cop27 will be there's
lots of talk around whether these
climate conferences are the way forward
this is what we have in the global
system
we are frustrated with the pace of
multilateralism I'm sure many other
countries are frustrated with the pace
of multilateralism uh it is about 200
countries that meet in this uh uh in in
the multilateral system they all need to
agree they all have interest and they
all have uh people and and interest of
uh of their voters as well as
communities within their country we have
to work these things through but this is
now on on the on the climate crisis it
is now time for leadership and leaders
are those that make the big and bold
decisions and lead from the front and uh
are not uh married to very vested and
narrow interests because Global
Leadership now requires Global action
with a sense of urgency uh with the far
greater speed and a much more skilled
climate action and this is a time for
for leaders to rise up to their Global
responsibility and we hope and we expect
that they will do okay Dr Prasad thank
you very much now is the time for
leadership very interesting isn't it
well it wasn't just loss and damage high
on the agenda this year the Disposable
waste it's always been a tricky subject
hasn't it in Africa only 11 of waste in
urban areas will go to manage landfills
which means the rest 90 is dumped or
simply burned and the burning of waste
isn't just contributing to Global
Climate Change scientists have linked it
to more than 1.2 million premature
deaths in Africa annually well joining
me now is Professor Desta mobrato a U.N
a high-level climate champion who helped
launched a new international partnership
at cop this year aiming to end the
burning of waste in Africa by 2040.
thank you so much for joining us today
straight away I mean how do you feel
about striking that deal at cop27 on
that global global level
thank you very much this is this is a
major development in fact when you look
at the issue of Open West Burning it was
only discussed at Corp Forum last year
at Glasgow in a side event So within one
year time it went through from up 26
Side Event to the United Nation
environment assembly the fifth
environmental assembly for African
cities Summit and ended up at the
African ministerial conference on
environment in September which passed a
resolution was a commitment of African
countries to eliminate Open West burning
from Africa so the partnership is an
implementation vehicle for that African
resolution for elimination of Open West
Burning so it is a major development for
us just tell our viewers how big a
problem open waste burning is not just
for people but the environment too
well open was burning basically produce
what we call the short-lived climate
pollutants which includes black carbon
particulate matters that traps number
one from the first place it's a shield
Subway the Sun and number two it traps
Heats it was in the atmosphere but
thereby contributing significantly for
global warming so this this this is this
is something which is a major
contributor for climate problem and it
is also a potential major contributor
for addressing the contributing to the
net zero effort by addressing this or
removing this short with climate
pollutants caused by Open West burning
and Professor we've been talking about
this on the show today there is a
conversation post cop 27 about how
useful these climate conferences are how
much really changes in those 12 months
from one climate conference to the next
how useful do you feel they are I mean
you signed this deal because of cop at
cop27 but moving forward is there
another way of dealing with these big
Global emergencies
I think since the launch of the United
Nations high-level Champions which is
tasked with the responsibility of
bringing or mobilizing non-step actors
that would help countries and
governments to move from commitment to
action we have seen a significant
progress at cop 26 and I think cop 27 is
also with its emphasis on action and
implementation it has shown that with
the active partnership between National
governments local governments businesses
and other United States actors we have a
chance of meeting at the 1.5 degree
Centigrade if we act fast but at least
we can achieve the two degrees
Centigrade limit so we we have seen
significant shift over the last couple
of years our hope is that within the
coming years within the coming corpse
the focus and emphasis on action and
implementation we have sufficient
level of claims and commitments it's
about time to move to action and the
partnership different modalities of
partnership are key in in realizing that
requirement for movement towards action
and implementation okay so we are
helpful with the progress right I I love
to hear the positivity coming out of all
these initiatives thank you so much
Professor Desta remember to thank you
for joining us on the daily climate show
now it's been a busy time in the world
of space exploration so NASA's Oreo and
Space Capsule has reached the moon for
the first time since the Apollo program
set out about 50 years ago and now talk
from the European Space Agency of a
three-year study to see if having
gigantic solar farms in outer space
could be foreseeable it's yet to be
confirmed but it would be groundbreaking
now the main goal a space-based
renewable energy generation system but
how would it work well let's take a look
for you well in space orbit the strength
of the sun is much higher than it is on
Earth and therefore solar panels in
space could capture all of that energy
and that would then be beamed back down
to earth captured and then potentially
sent back to the energy grid but we have
to leave the climate show now I'm going
to hand back to Sarah Jane